[Music]
if only mark ruffalo had a time machine
the actor who plays bruce banner and his
alter ego the hulk is a notorious
spoiler spiller
so obviously spoilers ahead in june 2017
ruffalo inadvertently gave away the
ending of avengers infinity war
during a good morning america interview
wait till you see this next one
everybody dies not everybody
no and in november 2017 he accidentally
live streamed part of thor ragnarok
during the film's world premiere
you gave away the whole movie didn't you
well only the first 10 minutes of it
and then during his october 2018
appearance on the late show with jimmy
fallon
ruffalo revealed the title of avengers
end game before it was officially
announced
i think it's out there already the the
the title
of the next avengers movie is
it was worth noting that ruffalo
actually said the last avenger but that
didn't stop end game co-directors joe
and anthony russo
from posting a tweet that read mark
you're fired well at least he kept his
mouth shut while promoting avengers ends
game right
wrong it turns out ruffalo actually did
spoil avengers end game
several weeks ago when he blurted out a
major plot point from the end of the
film
in an interview with e news alongside
captain america actor chris evans and
nebular actress karen gillan
ruffalo revealed that the russo brothers
had him shoot five different endings for
the film
he also revealed that the directing duo
never gave him a complete script
the actors said he didn't know the true
conclusion of endgame during filming
and he claimed that he'd have to wait
until the movie opened in theaters
to find out which ending was ultimately
chosen ruffalo explained
i didn't even get a whole script i don't
know why
i even got the script i did get had had
dummy scenes in it the story checks out
the russos have a history of withholding
full scripts from the actors
having done so with avengers infinity
war to keep story secrets close to the
chest
anyway at one point in the interview
ruffalo pointed to evans and
he gets married in this that's hilarious
right captain america tying the nut in
avengers end game like that would ever
happen
except it does happen though ruffalo was
offering an example of one of the dummy
scenes he actually revealed the real
ending to the superhero ensemble
avengers end game reveals that steve
rogers retires from being captain
america
after returning each infinity stone to
their proper places in time
he chooses to remain in the past
reuniting with his love peggy carter
and growing old with her steve later
resurfaces five years after the event of
infinity war
explaining to sam wilson that he chose
to go back in time to live the life he'd
always wanted
when steve shakes sam's hand we see a
wedding band steve stays mum on who the
wife is but a dance sequence between he
and peggy at the end of the film
proves that she's the lady in question
so yeah mark ruffalo totally spoiled
endgame but he probably didn't know he
was spoiling the film
it sounds like ruffalo's script was
choked full of fake scenes and he had no
way of knowing which ones were real
other actors in the mcu have been
similarly confused in the past
let's go back in time to tom holland's
april 2018 appearance on jimmy kimmel
live
while the cast was promoting avengers
infinity war holland revealed that he
didn't believe spider-man would ever
wind up in a sci-fi tizzy with thanos
i was reading what i thought was a fake
script because it was like spider-man's
in space
so i didn't finish it but i found out it
was real
that's the catch-22 of the russo
brothers fake scripts they succeed in
keeping the actors in the dark and
keeping spoilers from leaking but they
totally confused the cast to the point
that they don't know what's real or fake
ruffalo clearly thought the idea of
captain america getting married was too
ridiculous to be true
and he must have believed it was a fake
plot point that was okay to talk about
taking all of this into consideration we
can't place too much blame on ruffalo
fingers crossed he doesn't get fake
fired from the mcu a second time
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one